particularly fat women because fat is a  feminist issue men get fat and we just  go [ __ ] it all bought and paid for you  know  we don't come under the same constraints  of society whereas women are inundated  with  images of how you should be size zero  models this diet that diet look like  this keep your man and they make such an  effort don't they fat girls they've  always got lovely hair oh no they're  always having their hair done i've got  lovely hair always got lovely hair  always got those lovely false nails  they make an effort anything but jogging  right  they love high heels don't they  they think it makes their legs look less  it doesn't it just  you can just hear them coming now  [Applause]  i don't want any fat people to feel  uncomfortable at one of my gigs so next  time buy two seats i'm joking i'm  destined shut up